hello you're playing the waiting game
this is the show that eases the pain of
video game anticipation with similar
stuff it's like we're a big cultural
epidural and you're a pregnant lady
being fired out of the womb today the
Elder Scrolls online yes the franchise
you know and love famous for its huge
game world is reimagining the lot and
smashing it into one vast massively
multiplayer online game giving you free
reign over the entire realm of Tamriel
you join one of three warring factions
about a thousand years before the events
of Skyrim the Aldmeri Dominion the Bosma
and the ebonheart pact are all fighting
for the Emperor's throne when along
comes the Daedric Prince Molag Bal to
try and well destroy everything so
before you said about grinding your way
through the landscape of Tamriel
whatever can you do to whet your
appetite
okay yeah pretty obvious this one but I
promise I'm not trying to insult your
intelligence the Elder Scrolls 5 skyrim
is a bloody fantastic game chances are
you already know that if you really want
to use it to get prepped for the Elder
Scrolls online though you should pick it
up on PC and get yourself into modding
not only does it add hundreds of hours
of content from the canonical to the
completely bonkers if you get you used
to having other people influence your
game important considering you're going
to be playing an MMO and probably
fighting a lot of strangers for no
better reason than because they were
there we also do a show on Skyrim mods
it's called top 5 skyrim mods of the
week which is original are you sure
somewhere between a threatening stare
and the soldiers armed to the teeth yeah
yeah you had me if you like the idea of
learning how to get along with others in
the online open world but don't feel
Skyrim mods go far enough however
chances are you'll need something a bit
more hands-on for that I can thoroughly
recommend red dead redemption
multiplayer mode it's great to tool
around in you can posse up and go on
raids against computer flashpoints and
it's got a slightly more relaxed pace
than the more recent grand theft auto
online working finish get Julia your
Wang haft it's basically the closest
thing you're going to get to an MMO
without actually getting embroiled in
one because let's face it if you're
waiting for a massively multiplayer game
to come out the last thing you want to
do is throw yourself headlong into
another one now obviously running around
in the Wild West as cowboys and shooting
each other's horses in the head is a
pretty far cry from the Elder Scrolls
let's take a look at that story one more
time shall we now Moloch ball is an evil
chappie who gets referenced in Skyrim
you can even bag his mace after doing a
little quest if you like I give
true power immortal anyway his deal is
basically the conquest and enslavement
of mortals he tries to spread discord
and conflict throughout the mortal realm
hoping to then harvest the tasty souls
of mortals after that now I have a soul
in Oblivion it's clean take care of the
house
and apart from the whole soul eating bit
that kind of sounds like a fellow called
Sauron Lord of the Rings is the
incredibly popular trilogy of books by
JRR Tolkien arguably the most
significant fantasy work ever it's also
been adapted for the screen in case
you're wondering why books can suddenly
move in all of the Rings the Dark Lord
Sauron not dissimilar to Molag Bal wants
to crush the realm of man and take over
the whole land by being straight up evil
while he doesn't physically feature much
at all in Lord of the Rings Sirhan's
constant menace is nonetheless enough to
drive the action forward much in the
same way our daedric friend will form
the backdrop to the Elder Scrolls online
three-way civil conflict also quite
similar to the plot of the Elder Scrolls
online is dragon age origins we're not
recommending dragon age 2 that was
rubbish dragon age is a high fantasy RPG
from bioware in which you play a warrior
mage or rogue in the kingdom of Ferelden
which is currently in a state of civil
uproar it's up to you to unite the land
in order to fight off invading demonic
forces to be honest it all sounds like a
bit of a bore lake but trust me when I
say it's actually really rather
rewarding to play as well as a varied
plot of six origin stories that combat
has a satisfying depth allowing you to
issue orders and cue special attacks for
NPCs in your group as accomplished as
dragon age origins is however it would
still be nowhere without its spiritual
predecessor boulders gate also developed
by Bioware Baldur's Gate is a franchise
launched in 1998 and famed for bringing
new life to computer based rpgs its
crammed with NPCs dialogue player
choices and a reputation system features
now common fare in RPGs to be sure but
playing through the series that sparked
it all is an excellent way to understand
the genre you're throwing yourself
toward in the Elder Scrolls online even
if the relative scales are pretty wildly
divergent best of all the first two
Boulder's gates have recently been
re-released on PC Mac Android and iOS in
enhanced editions hooray and if all that
page turning and button bashing is tied
out your hands but
your appetite for violence you could
always watch some Vikings mash each
other's heads in with axes having
finished its first season just last year
it tells the story of one of the best
known Norse heroes Ragnar lothbrok as he
pioneers the first Viking raids into
northern England it goes quite well for
him which causes all sorts of trouble at
home drama and violence Bothans you he
so chances are your adventures in the
elder scrolls online won't have someone
coveting your wife or envying how fast
your long boats are but Vikings are
still a fairly entertaining romp and
will at least help you kill some time
before the elder scrolls online launches
speaking of which I hope you make it
till launch day because I'm off now as
ever if you want to check out the stuff
we discussed in this episode follow the
link on screen now for an amazon list
I'll be back next week but in the
meantime feel free to make your own
recommendations by leaving a comment or
tweeting with a hashtag GS waiting game
see ya